joyeux anniversaire maintenant les gens
ils disent plus bonne anniversaire en
vrai dit le disent sur ton mur facebook
et vu que écrire simplement joyeux
anniversaire c'est un peu banal
on dirait que chacun essaie de trouver
une formulation un petit peu originale
de manière avec le pote un peu plus cool
que les autres grosses peuple d'en bas
il y en a même certains qui écrivent hb
l'abréviation d' happy birthday gens les
mecs ils ont même pas le temps d'écrire
le mot en entier quoi je suis un tout
petit peu dit par contre est ce que tu
te fais pas achevé on peut se faire un
café ce dès fois ton anniversaire tes
potes ils veulent d'organiser une fête
surprise
ce qui est grave sympa mais souvent tout
le sens un peu venir quand même eh les
mecs demain c'est mon anniversaire tête
comme pour organiser une petite fête non
non moi je mets pas moche parce que j'ai
un cancer vite fait du coup j'avais
l'estomac
alors qu'en fait merci je m'attendais
pas du tout faux c'est marrant parce
qu'on dirait que en fonction de ton âge
les gens se sentent obligés de faire le
commentaire de politesse obligatoire que
tout le monde fait à chaque fois
18 ans la majorité 20 ans la vente n 21
ans la majorité international 25 ans un
quart de siècle 26 ans va alors ça y est
à 26 ans 40 ans la dépression 65 ans ça
y est c'est la retraite 80 ans
ça y est bientôt tu vas mourir à la
tienne quand la soirée d'anniversaire
bat son plein que les gens s'amusent qui
a une bonne ambiance
tout d'un coup les lumières s'éteignent
et alors là on sait tous que ça veut
dire pardon c'était c'est moi qui a
pillé sans faire exprès avec mon coude
je suis désolé ah oui un truc concernant
les bougies d'anniversaire qui se
rallument tout seul est-ce qu'il ya
encore un mec sur la planète terre que
ça fait rigoler non josé nniversaire
c'est vraiment une chanson un peu bof tu
vois un peu festive mais ça qu'on aime
et moi lymphome anniversaire ya un mec
qui voulait absolument montrer qu'ils
savaient bien chanter mais faut pas le
faire sur ce morceau là le mec vraiment
pas joué
mercer
anniversaire
je suis en enlever alors ça fait alors
j'espère pourquoi à chaque fois qu'on
les bougies sont soufflées en général il
ya tout le monde qui crient à ce moment
là je deviens hyper timide et le seul
discours que j'arrive à sortir c'est me
merci et je me disais les hommes
politiques qui font des discours toute
la journée à la télé à ce moment là
quand ça leur anniversaire ils doivent
être archi bon si vous êtes là ce soir
c'est parce que comme tous les français
vous voulez vous ambiancer et vous avez
raison on ne pense pas assez akimova nsa
qui ont gonflé les ballons 1,1 à la
seule force de leurs poumons
merci à tous quand tous ces cadeaux
devant tout le monde et que tu reçois un
cadeau super nul hein ça arrive c'est
gênant parce que tu es quand même obligé
de faire genre t'es content à habas et
un pull
c'est un pull ben moi je sais même style
que moi ah ouais ouais donc plus moi
j'adore ce genre de pub je vais j'ai
déjà envie de le mettre
merci franchement les cadeaux
d'anniversaire peu importe le prix il ya
toujours moyen de trouver un truc cool
mettait les cadeaux fun et a toujours ce
mec qui t'offre ce cadeau qui cassent
l'ambiance à un livre tu es content à
merci c'est parce que je sais que rien
dire en vrai à ce moment là tu aimerais
être offert un livre emballé connu je
suis vous remercie qu'est ce que c'est
en plus le mec qui t'offre un livre en
général ils aiment bien commencé à
traquer jusque là dedans
histoire de justifier son cadeau moyens
alors que franchement c'est pas le
moment
ce lavoir super intéressant
ce que ça raconte l'histoire de la
bataille de verdun à temps plus
précisément les l'histoire d'un soldat
et s attend à ce que certains maires des
belges mais sont claires avec les
français ah ouais les mecs qui ont pas
acheter de cadeaux
en général ils disent toujours alors
pourquoi moi j'ai pas de cadeau là je
veux pas pour l'instant mais là je vais
en acheter un mardi ou mercredi
normalement tu peux l'avoir vers samedi
à peu près ok voilà les anniversaires
cela veut dire que tu ne l'aura jamais
quoi qu'il en soit cas d'opa cadeau
quand c'est notre anniversaire ça fait
toujours plaisir qu'on nous le souhaite
alors si aujourd'hui c'est le vôtre je
tenais à vous le dire joyeuses pâques
si vous êtes là ce soir c'est parce que
vous voulez vous ambiancer et vous avez
merci pour ces cas là c'est grave
avec plaisir